would you rather be bald by age 20 or  5'3 with a full head of hair  bald i'm going to be bald shortly yeah  i'm i'm guessing by  mid-40s 50 i'll be bald so i'll do bald  oh you're coming don't you dare dude no  i don't care i'm going bald  as like a younger guy like you say your  early 20s  when you're young dude just be bald just  be bald  people care about hair too much pretty  gay  if you're a dude worried about your hair  congratulations i got a weird head  you can carry a little you don't care  too much yeah you got a big dome though  that thing goes bald it's gonna be  [ __ ] right look at his head dude  he's a size eight are you  chin the talk dude  hold on put your hands there and let me  move my head  yeah that's a quack